une réforme majeure il a le champ des
possibles de dimension ya ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur il ya quelques jours était
lancée par deux députés socialistes ce
qui fut appelé pompeusement l'appel de
marseille qui demandait la législation
la légalisation de la consommation de
cannabis dans notre pays
la motivation de cet appel monsieur
ministre va sûrement vous faire plaisir
la prohibition du cannabis pour eux est
un échec responsable de plus de 30 morts
violentes à marseille d'ailleurs ces
deux députés socialistes parlent même
d'un désastre et indique donc que la
seule solution finalement serait la
légalisation de la culture de la vente
et de la consommation du cannabis le
gouvernement d'ailleurs est un peu
victime de ses propres contradictions
le premier ministre lui-même a indiqué
il ya quelques années et qu'il était
favorable à un débat monsieur le guen
idem tout comme monsieur peillon quand
il était ministre de l'éducation
sans parler bien sûr maintenant des
candidats à la primaire de gauche 5 sur
7 serait pour cela et même le si
respectable monsieur macron nous ne
partageons pas nous les républicains
cette position laxiste qui constitue un
renoncement de plus de l'état et qui de
toute façon ne supprimera pas évidemment
le trafic illicites le cannabis est
évidemment dangereux pour la santé
et ce serait un message incompréhensible
pour le gouvernement de prendre des
mesures anti alcool anti tabac et le
prenez la légalisation du cannabis
seul ministre la priorité du
gouvernement devrait être de réduire la
consommation des drogues en france et
non la légaliser monsieur le ministre je
vais donc vous poser une question très
directe en tant que président du groupe
socialiste en octobre 2015
vous étiez déclaré favorable un débat
sur la vente par l'état de cannabis aux
consommateurs
aujourd'hui en tant que ministre avez
vous changé d'avis y êtes-vous aux côtés
de la police et dans la justice pour
lutter contre le trafic de drogue
merci la parole est à madame ségolène
neuville secrétaire d'état chargé des
personnes handicapées et de la lutte
contre l'exclusion et je vous rappelle
merci monsieur que c'est beaucoup
demander si le début est calé dominique
tian présent votre enthousiasme qui me
fait qui me réchauffe le coeur je
voudrais vous dire que marisol touraine
comme moi même avons déjà répondu à de
nombreuses reprises à cette question et
je me demande s'il approche d'échéances
électorales importantes ne fait pas que
cette question arrive à lui même
aujourd'hui dans vos propos je voudrais
très clair la consommation de cannabis
est désastreuse pour la santé et en
particulier par la santé des jeunes
c'est quelque chose qui est clairement
montré et la consommation de cannabis en
france est interdite et jamais le
gouvernement depuis 2012 jamais ce
gouvernement ni le gouvernement de jean
mas qui a créé ronnie le gouvernement de
manuel valls n'ont eu l'intention de
remettre en cause cette interdiction
nous avons toujours été extrêmement
clair sur cette question
précisément parce que l'objectif le seul
objectif qui compte c'est de réduire la
consommation qui est beaucoup trop
importante
beaucoup trop importante puisqu'on
estime qu'il y à un million quatre
d'usagers qui en consomment plusieurs
fois dans le mois
néanmoins il y à une étude récente sur
les jeunes et en particulier sur les
lycéens qui montre que cette
consommation diminue chez les lycéens en
europe et en france puisqu'elle serait
passé en europe et 11 et 2015 de 49 à 44
% pour les usages en cours dans l'année
qui précède je veux terminer en vous
disant que vous devriez aussi faire
connaître beaucoup plus les 540 points
d'accueil pour les jeunes il lutte
contre les addictions le cannabis mais
aussi l'alcool ces points là il y en a
sur l'ensemble du territoire il y en a
tiens marseille monsieur tian et je vous
encourage à les faire connaître